hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
this video we're going to talk about how
to find the derivative using the
difference quotient so what's exciting
about this video is that we're starting
to leave precalculus and start to get
into actual calculus and so I just want
to kind of set the framework here for
you to help you understand this better
what exactly is a derivative so let's
talk about that what is a derivative
well let's start off by looking at this
graph right here see this curve okay
what we're gonna do is we're going to
pick two points along the curve and
we're in a draw secant okay so that's
this line right here that cuts through
the curve at two points and I'm going to
label this first point X f of X meaning
if I put the x value into the function f
out comes the output f of X right if I
go a little bit further to the right
we'll call that distance H now I'm at X
plus h and if I go up to the function
okay up to the graph my output is f of X
plus h remember whatever is in the
parentheses that's the input half of X
plus h that's the output that's the
y-value so now what we're going to do is
we're going to find the slope between
these two points now you can see what's
happening is here this graph is actually
starting off at a very steep angle and
it's getting less and less steep as it
goes along right but between these two
points we're finding the average rate of
change okay or the average slope okay or
the average increase between these two
points and so we're going to use our
slope formula you probably remember from
before the slope formula is y2 minus y1
over x2 minus x1 so all I did is I took
this Y value minus this Y value f of X
plus h minus f of X okay divided by this
x value minus this x value so X plus h
minus X sorry you're with me so far so
all we're doing is we're just finding a
formula for the slope ok so M equals the
change in Y over the change in X that's
what these triangles means at Delta Y
divided by Delta X
the change in Y means were subtracting
the y-values the change in X means we're
subtracting the x-values that's our
formula for the slope
okay the rise over run sometimes you
learn it that way and then all I'm doing
is I'm substituting in these values here
okay to get to get where I'm at right
here with the difference quotient okay
so now we're gonna change the notation
up a little bit for you so instead of
writing M for the slope we're gonna
write f prime of X so this little
apostrophe here we say F prime and this
is actually the derivative okay
sometimes it's written as dy DX okay
so dy is like Delta Y like the change in
Y over the change in X and in order to
find out what this derivative is we're
just doing the difference quotient so
difference means you're subtracting
quotient means we're dividing so
together they call it the difference
quotient but you can see here this X and
this negative X they cancelled out just
leaving us with H and the denominator so
it simplifies down a little bit now as H
approaches zero we're doing a limit here
what that means is this distance is
getting smaller smaller smaller smaller
so that means this point is moving along
this curve okay until these two points
actually coincide okay so the difference
between these points is getting smaller
until what happens is you're getting not
the average rate of change but the
instantaneous rate of change let me see
if I can draw that in here for us like
that okay because this point is moving
along the curve like that as H is
getting smaller and smaller so you're
with me so far okay so all the
derivative is what's the derivative it's
a formula for the slope anyplace along
the graph so what we're gonna do is
really actually when we simplify the
difference quotient we're gonna get an
expression okay that'll allow us to find
out when we put the X value in what the
slope is at that point along the graph
let's do some examples you'll see what I
mean this first one this is kind of a
simple one f of X equals 2x minus 3 okay
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to do the difference quotient so f
of X plus h minus f of X okay so if I
put X plus h in for X what do I get I
get let me switch markers here for us
okay this is going to be 2 times X plus
h minus 3 okay
minus f of X f of X is this an original
function here so I'm going to put it in
parenthesis minus 2x minus 3 all divided
by H okay so now if I distribute and
simplify we get 2x plus 2h minus 3 I'm
going to distribute this negative here
so I get a negative 2x plus 3 all
divided by H and you can see the 2x and
the negative 2x cancel the 3 and the
negative 3 cancel and we have to H
divided by H the H is canceled and
remember with the difference quotient
okay this is the limit as H is
approaching 0 okay but you can see here
we're just left with 2 okay so now why
just two well if you look at this
equation here you can see this is
actually the formula for a line if we
were to graph this line what would it
look like it has a y-intercept of
negative 3 and it has a slope of 2 so it
looks something like that
so no matter where you are along this
line the slope is always going to be 2
so remember the difference quotient the
derivative okay and the slope these all
mean the same thing the slope is always
a constant
- ok let's do a more challenging example
so this one here we're going to do the
same thing we're going to use our
difference quotient ok so what do we
have we have 1/2 of X plus h minus f of
X all divided by H ok so we're going to
put X plus h in place of X so wherever
we see X on the right side we're going
to replace it with what we're putting in
for X which is X plus h that's our input
we've got X plus h squared plus 2 times
X plus h ok so that's all this first
part here minus f of X f of X is this
whole original function so I'm just
going to substitute that in
all / h okay now the rest of this is
just arithmetic but let's see if we can
simplify it down so we have x squared
plus 2h X plus h squared when we foil
that out plus 2x plus 2h minus x squared
minus 2x all divided by H okay so we're
going to cancel out the X Squared's the
2x is also cancel and we're left with 2h
x plus h squared plus 2h all divided by
H now you can factor out an H in the
numerator and you're left with 2x plus h
plus 2 all divided by H and you can see
these H's are going to cancel cancel out
so now keep in mind that we're actually
finding the limit as h approaches 0 so
at this point we're left with 2x plus h
plus 2 as h approaches 0 i'm going to
put 0 in place of h so that's gone so
that's just going to be 2x plus 2 so
what we have now is f prime of x okay
which represents our derivative remember
equals 2x plus 2 so what does this mean
well depending on what X is the slope
okay the derivative represents the slope
the slope is going to be changing so
let's take a look at what this graph
looks like let's see if we can draw a
sketch right here so let's factor this
so if we factor this this is going to be
x times X plus 2 so that means it's
going to be crossing at 0 and negative 2
that means the axis of symmetry is going
to be at negative 1 if we put a negative
1 what do we get negative 1 times 1
which is negative 1 so it looks just
like that all right so it's a parabola
okay so notice what happens let's say x
equals 1 if we put 1 in 2 times 1 is 2
plus 2 is 4 so that means if we go over
here at 1 this is curving up a little
bit more like that if we go here to 1
and we go up to 2 the point on the graph
it corresponds with x equals 1 that's
slope okay that instantaneous rate of
change is 4 okay now let's say we put in
x equals negative 1 negative 1 that's
going to be negative
two plus two which is zero okay so at x
equals negative one we go down to the
graph yep that makes sense that's zero
because it's changing direction say we
do x equals negative two we're getting
negative 4 plus 2 which is negative 2 so
at this point you can see it has a
negative 2 slope so I hope this cleared
up you know any confusion or just any
questions you had about you know what
the derivative is and how you use the
difference quotient and what it all
represents just remember it's just a
formula for the slope but we're using
limits and that's what makes it the
derivative so you're actually finding
not the average rate of change but the
instantaneous rate of change it's the
slope of the tangent line at that point
to the curve so I hope you enjoyed the
video subscribe to the channel check out
some of my future videos and some of my
past videos and I'll see you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon